hello students faculty and Friends of
Hillsdale College my name is Mariah
Hardy I'm from the great state of Oregon
and I am a junior here at Hillsdale
studying international business and
German I'm involved on campus and my
sorority Chi Omega and as a student
ambassador for Hillsdale College
Admissions today I have the honor of
introducing you to mr. Peter Schiff
Peter Schiff is the CEO and chief global
strategist of Euro Pacific Capital here
in a degree in finance and accounting
from UC Berkeley in 1987 mr. Schiff
served as an economic adviser to Ron
Paul in the 2008 presidential campaign
he is widely quoted in numerous
publications including The Wall Street
Journal Barron's investors business
daily the Financial Times The New York
Times the Los Angeles Times and The
Washington Post he is a frequent guest
on CNBC CNN Fox News and the Fox
Business Network mr. Schiff is the
author of numerous books including how
an economy grows and why it crashes
crash-proof
how to profit from the coming economic
collapse and most recently the real
crash America's coming bankruptcy how to
save yourself and your country please
join me in welcoming mr. Peter Schiff
you
a lot of steps over there
you know it's a little bit of an old
intro I wonder if I need to update that
cuz you know I used to be a frequent
guest on all those media outlets but now
I don't know maybe I'm an infrequent
guest I'm on once in a while I'm on
television more often outside the United
States and then inside the United States
I think I think I got too many things
right to to be invited back and I guess
sa good lead-in to the topic I read the
topic of my talk on the plane on the way
over here so I'm talking about the Fed
and and and and what we're supposed to
think of it and you know I mean it's
it's really like you know like from from
Star Wars right what are the bad guys
the you know well not that know that's
that Star Trek that's Star Trek whatever
the evil empire whatever the Death Star
I mean the the Federal Reserve is is a
is a very bad very bad organization a
very evil entity I think that most of
the problems yeah I mean most of the
problems that we have can be laid at the
foot of the Federal Reserve I mean not
that the Federal Reserve acts you know
is the sole source of our problems but
most of the problems could really be a
trace to the Federal Reserve and the
Federal Reserve is certainly responsible
for I think the degradation of the
American economy the artificially low
interest rates that have prevailed you
know for most the last probably 20 years
I mean particularly the last seven years
they're at zero now but even prior to
that the Federal Reserve has been
artificially suppressing interest rates
just you know price fixing the cost of
credit with disastrous consequences for
the real economy I think as a result of
what the Fed has done the Fed has
discouraged in under
mind capital investment savings you know
legitimate investment production and the
other side they have encouraged and
subsidized reckless consumption
speculation all of this has helped
transform the American economy from an
industrial powerhouse to the world's
largest debtor nation and we exist
basically as the supposed consumer based
economy where all we do is buy things
that are made in other countries and
borrow the money in order to do it and
what the Fed has created and replace of
the economy they've helped destroy is a
gigantic bubble and yes they've been
able to elevate the stock market and
they've been able to elevate the bond
market in the real estate market and
rare art and collectible automobiles and
all sorts of asset prices have gone way
up but at the same time they have been
the principal I think architect of this
widening divide between the very rich
and everybody else particularly what
used to be the American middle class and
the lower class and in fact that's
helping to fuel a lot of this class
warfare where members of you know it
used to be the middle class at the lower
classes are taking out their anger and
their frustration at what they perceive
to be the source of their problem not
recognizing you know I was just at an
event in Jackson Hole but did anybody go
to that event yeah it was Irv meets
every every year in Jackson Hole and
it's a very big televised conference you
know and I was there to participate in a
in a very critical event critical the
Federal Reserve right and so it was a
protest event and I was one of the
speaker's well there was another
organization that was there criticizing
the Fed black lives matter and they were
there to demand that the Fed not raise
interest rates
and you know I think the Federal Reserve
really encouraged this protest maybe
behind the scenes because the event that
I was at tried to book the same venue
the same hotel where the Fed was meeting
and they were told no no you can't be in
this hotel it's only for the Fed and so
we they had to have a place a couple
miles down the road this organization
was in the same location as the Fed and
they came up with the idea a lot
you know later than the organization I
was speaking at so I think the Federal
Reserve had something to do I think they
liked this protest because the protests
basically validated everything the Fed
was doing because the protesters who had
been bussed in by the labor unions they
didn't even heard of the Fed until they
showed up right but the protesters had
these signs that people had written for
them and you know they wanted they said
you know there's what inflation there's
no inflation you know we need jobs you
know keep don't raise rates and the
whole idea was that somehow what the Fed
is doing is creating jobs is growing the
economy and the protesters don't want
the Fed to stop doing all this good
stuff as if somehow just creating money
for any money right taking paper and
putting you know numbers on it somehow
doing this is going to generate economic
prosperity economic economic growth and
and and that we need inflation in fact I
was reading this article just today this
morning it was an article that was
quoting me but the headline didn't quote
me I had said some negative comments
about the economy and the headline in
the article was consumers feel the sting
of low inflation feel the sting of low
inflation so let me get to so a consumer
is showing up at a store and it's like
oh my gosh I thought this was going to
be more expensive it's cheaper that I
thought this really stings
what am I going to do with this extra
money that I didn't spend this feeling
asleep I mean I was talking about how
the economy was weak but the Federal
Reserve has been able to succeed with
their propaganda effort to convince
everybody that inflation is a good thing
and their job is to create it right
how's that for a 180 right because
people you say oh the Federal Reserve is
here to fight inflation now they're here
to create inflation to fight the absence
of inflation right they used to say we
want to we want price stability
well price stability means no inflation
now they redefine price stability to
prices rising by at least two percent a
year and if they're not rising by at
least that much we have to take decisive
action to make sure that prices go up
because somehow if prices don't go up
all right then
we're going to the economy is going to
implode into some kind of vortex right
and so that this this this is the
propaganda effort that the Federal
Reserve has been able to successfully
you know indoctrinate almost the entire
world at this point into believing that
a rising cost of living is it economic
necessity that somehow if the cost of
living were to go down that we would all
suffer as a result of that but so the
Federal Reserve has been the main I
think barrier to economic growth to
progress yes I mean the federal
government is also complicit but if it
wasn't for the Fed if the Federal
Reserve wasn't willing to accommodate
all this government spending by
monetizing it and by keeping interest
rates artificially low the government
would have had to come to terms with its
insolvency years ago the government
would have been forced to cut spending
years ago had the Federal Reserve not
cooperated not kept interest rates
artificially low so if you're upset
about big government and the growth of
government look no further than the
Federal Reserve because the Federal
Reserve is enabling it to happen and the
Fed pretends like hey we've got no
choice here you know we just have to
accommodate the GUP no they don't the
whole idea behind the Federal Reserve
it's supposed to be independent but they
don't act independent at all they act
like a branch of the government an arm
of the federal government and they're
there to facilitate government spending
and government deficits but the problem
is because of what the Federal Reserve
has done the deficits have been able to
grow to levels that never could have
existed in fact when they first started
the Federal Reserve in 1913 the Federal
Reserve was not even allowed to buy US
government debt right the people had
created the Federal Reserve we're smart
enough to say look we don't want the
government to be able to borrow from the
Federal Reserve we don't want that to
happen right and so that was not part of
the Federal Reserve's mission and they
probably wouldn't even be able to get
the votes to create it if it was going
to be an engine of inflation but what
happened as often as the case is we got
ourselves into World War 1 and whenever
we end up getting in war all of a sudden
governments you know usurp a lot of
power that during peacetime the public
would never allow them to take but once
there you get a war and all of a sudden
it's patriotism well the government is
able to use that to do all sorts of very
unpatriotic things and they able to get
away with it because you know it's a war
and so one of the things that happened
in the war is they amended the Federal
Reserve Act to enable the Federal
Reserve to buy US Treasuries they
weren't allowed to do it before why
because they the government wanted to
finance the war and and that made it
easier now and other than it just
happened right it was that the Congress
unfortunately voted to suspend the debt
ceiling you know they used to raise the
debt ceiling now they just eliminate it
for a period of time right they don't
even have the integrity to raise it
because they're embarrassed about
putting a new number right so they just
suspended every once in a while so they
don't have to be accused of raising it
right instead of you know voting you
know to leave it where it is
but the reason we even have a debt
ceiling in the first place is because
when the Federal Reserve Act was amended
in order to
enable the government to borrow from the
Fed and the Fed to buy Treasuries
Congress was worried that this
relationship could result in too much
debt that the government would take
advantage of this and so they passed a
debt ceiling they said ok we're going to
make a ceiling here and say look this is
the highest this is the most debt we're
going to allow that was part of the
whole process well obviously it didn't
work the ceiling should have been a
constitutional amendment or something it
should have been you know a ceiling that
could never go up but unfortunately that
ceiling has been raised every time it's
been approached you know until just
recently when it's just been suspended
but because of the federal reserve the
government is enormous the government
never could have grown to the size that
it is if it had to pay for its
activities with real money if it
actually had a tax the citizens for all
of the spending the citizens would have
objected to this to the spending people
want something for nothing they don't
want something if they have to pay for
it right but the government was able to
probably promise something for nothing
but all this was from the Fed and I
think because of the Fed the United
States today is on the verge of the
biggest economic catastrophe in the
history of the country and you know if
you thought the 2008 financial crisis
was bad that's nothing compared to
what's coming that was just to warm up
right the main event is still coming and
because of what the Federal Reserve did
in the aftermath of that crisis to make
all the problems that caused the crisis
worse it's going to be so much worse
when we actually have to deal with the
real economic crisis that is still
coming and what's going to really
exacerbate it is that the Federal
Reserve still doesn't understand its
role in causing that problem to this day
Ben Bernanke you know he's going around
promoting his book right he's got a new
book out you know the the courage to act
I mean how much courage does it take to
print money hey the real title of the
book should be a coward's way out
and in fact you know what I see you know
you you see that book it's in the
airport bookstore - it's a if you see
that book on a shelf move it to the
fiction section because that's where it
belongs right but he's out there
promoting his book like he saved the
country right and I talked to him I ran
into him at a conference in Las Vegas
where we were both speaking I spoke for
free he got $250,000 to speak but um but
anyway so we're speaking at this
investment conference and I I got up I
talked to him in a cocktail party about
the crisis and the guy is still so
clueless about the Fed he thinks that
the Federal Reserve's 1% interest rates
had nothing to do with the housing
bubble nothing it was just a sheer
random coincidence that we had a housing
bubble and we happen to have these 1%
interest rates right well it wasn't a
coincidence
because the minute the Fed lowered
interest rates to 1% in 2002 I began
warning that this was going to produce a
you know a disaster and by 2004 I knew
exactly what the disaster was and I
started writing I started going around
the country talking I was uh you know
going on television talking about the
housing bubble about how the Federal
Reserve had created that bubble and what
the consequences were going to be for
the economy when the bubble burst so I
knew about the bubble because I
understood the Fed was causing it the
same time that I was out there warning
about a bubble people like Ben Bernanke
and Janet Yellen were denying that a
housing bubble existed even after it
burst
these guys were denying even Janet
Yellen you know when when Janet Yellen
was appointed chairman the Federal
Reserve I everybody said she is the
brightest one on the Fed because she was
the one that was warning about the
housing bubble and nobody listened to
her and you know if we only had Janet
Yellen at the helm everything would have
been great I mean even President Obama
said this when he appointed her during
the press conference she warned about
the crisis hey well I actually did
research on it and I find out that she
didn't warn about anything in fact the
very speeches where Janet Yellen is
credited for having warned I went back
and read those speeches and not only did
she not warn about anything she actually
said that the people who were worried
about the housing market were wrong she
said there was no housing bubble that
housing prices reflected the
fundamentals and even as late as 2006
she expected housing prices to keep
rising and she said if she's wrong if I
end up being wrong and housing prices go
down it's not going to hurt the economy
that's how she was as clueless as you
could possibly be I did a YouTube video
got Janet Yellen exposed so if you want
to you know you have some time you want
to watch that video you can actually I
highlight all the things that she said
she was as close as you can be so now
you know it's the blind leading the
blind
having Janet Yellen and she was the
chairs president of the Federal Reserve
Bank of San Francisco during the entire
bubble right I mean California was you
know one of the biggest problem areas
California that area in Las Vegas so she
was right there and had no idea so the
Federal Reserve is composing clueless
about how its very policies caused the
2008 financial crisis and now they've
pursued the same policies on steroids
and if you can remember what happened in
2008 right all the bad things that were
supposedly about to happen that resulted
from the Federal Reserve keeping
interest rates at 1% for I don't know
less than two years a year and a half
and then the Federal Reserve raised
interest rates in a measured pace which
was every time they met they hiked them
a quarter of a point so it took another
year and a half to get interest rates
back up to 5% where they were before the
Fed slashed them to one and so it was
during that three years really that the
biggest part of the damage was
that's when most of the subprime loans
were taken out the adjustable rate
mortgages the no-doc the interest only I
mean all this was facilitated by the
cheap money that was supplied by the
Federal Reserve and of course you know
once they got the speculative mania
going it just fed on itself right but
but they lit the sparks with that policy
and we had all this malinvestment that
took place because interest rates were
too low well if the Fed did all that
damage by keeping interest rates at 1%
and then raising them back to 5% slowly
imagine the degree of damage that has
been done over the last seven years
where interest rates have been at zero
the entire time and the Fed has tripled
its balance sheet how much how much more
screwed up is the economy now than it
was in 2008 before the crisis and the
crisis is the way the market tries to
repair all the problems that the Fed has
created right well there's a lot more
problems now the country is so much more
indebted the structure of the economy is
so much more screwed up and Janet Yellen
isn't even talking about raising
interest rates back up to normal even if
the Fed raises interest rates in
December which I still don't think
they're going to do you know they've
been talking about this for a year or
two but even if she raises interest
rates from zero to 0.25 it's still a
quarter of what when it was at one and
she's talking about how even if we raise
interest rates to a half a quarter of a
percent we're going to be really slow
before we raise them again I mean they
may never raise them again so the degree
to which the Fed has screwed up the
economy this time it's it's off the
charts compared to 2008 and I think what
makes everything so so dangerous it is
not only does the Fed not have any clue
about how its policies so you know cause
the 2008 financial crisis they still
don't understand what caused the Great
Depression you know they have learned
the complete opposite
no the Federal Reserve made mistakes but
in the 1920s those were the mistakes in
the latter half of the 1920s the Federal
Reserve kept interest rates too low they
did that deliberately I mean their goal
was to try to prop up the British Pound
and so they they wanted to keep the
pound from falling so they lowered
interest rates in the United States but
they shouldn't have done that and by
doing that they created a speculative
bubble in the stock market and in the
real estate market and eventually the
Fed raised interest rates and pricked
the bubble and the bubble popped in 1929
but it wouldn't have been that big a
deal I mean it probably would have gone
on for a year I mean there wouldn't have
been a Great Depression but what
happened is Herbert Hoover who was the
president at the time decided that he
didn't want to have a market-based
approach which had been the norm in the
past
normally the free market the government
stayed out of it and if there was tough
times the government did what everybody
else did the government tightened its
belt the government cut spending if the
economy was weak he cut spending you
know you make yourself a smaller burden
on on a weaker economy right but instead
Hoover decided to be the first president
to do a stimulus and he tried to
intervene he tried to prop pop things up
and cost he ended up creating a
depression and then Roosevelt came in
and expanded all those failed programs
and it became a great depression right
so but the way Ben Bernanke looks at the
depression right and the mistakes that
were made
he thinks the mistake wasn't lowering
interest rates but the fact that they
ever raised them he thinks that you know
that the solution and this is what the
Fed thinks it's a solution to problems
that are brought about by interest rates
being too low and government spending
too much is to make interest rates even
lower and for the governor to spend even
more money that's how you're supposed to
solve these problems but if you're in a
big ditch you just keep digging and that
supposedly is going to get you out so
this is the mindset of Janet Yellen and
her cohorts at the Federal Reserve so it
is a very scary
position to be in given what's about to
happen because when the last crisis
happened yes the Federal Reserve was
able to bail everybody out and postpone
a lot of the pain because a lot of the
bad debt that was owned by the private
sector is now owned by the government
and the government's liabilities have
just skyrocketed and so the next step is
going to be a crisis at the sovereign
level right not at the private level but
at the government level where the US
government is going to go through a
crisis in the dollar and in the bond
market where people are going to lose
confidence in the value of the dollar
and the US government's ability to pay
its debts with money that has value you
know right now people aren't worried
about the fact that we have an eighteen
and a half trillion dollar debt
because they know that we could print
money to pay it right they're not
worried but at some point they're going
to have to worry about that and it's not
just eighteen and a half trillion we owe
you know 100 trillion or whatever it is
if you count all the unfunded off-budget
type liabilities that are not part of
the Treasury but one of the reasons why
the Federal Reserve has kept interest
rates at zero is because if interest
rates were allowed to rise the US
government couldn't afford to service
the debt let alone retire it right we're
always spending about two hundred and
fifty billion or so a year on interest
on the debt even though the debt you
know is again approaching twenty
trillion by the time Barack Obama leaves
office the national debt will be about
twenty trillion which is about double
what it was when he came into office
right which means that President Obama
actually would have added more to the
national debt than George Washington to
George W Bush combined but you know Bush
Bush did the same thing Bush 43 he
doubled the debt during his eight years
so Obama doubled it again so it what can
Hillary possibly double it from twenty
trillion to 40 trillion is that even
possible that's the trajectory that were
on
but is it even is it even within the
realm of possibility that we could do
that I don't think so I think we're
going to have a crisis in the bond
market and the dollar long before that
happens the only reason that we've had
this rally in the dollar is because the
whole world is convinced that what the
Federal Reserve did worked right that
what the monetary policy that they
pursued you know fix the problem save
the economy and that now the Fed can
withdraw the stimulus the Fed could
raise interest rates shrink its balance
sheet and everything is great and
because everybody believes that they've
they've bought the dollar but the crisis
is going to come when people realize
that that's not the case
adda Federal Reserve didn't restore the
economy to health right they were saying
like look the economy needs a little
help right just you know give it a
crutch like let's the Federal Reserve's
you know in until the economy gets back
on its feet we'll give it this crutch
you know zero percent interest rates and
then you know when the economy is
healthy again it will take it away won't
need it anymore that's not what actually
happened right we the economy and get a
crutch basically the Federal Reserve
chopped off the legs and gave the
economy prosthetics and quantitative
easing and 0% industries and that's the
only thing that's supporting the economy
you can't take you can't take those
prosthetics away do you think that you
can't walk there's the big that when
people realize that all this is is a
bubble right and Ben Bernanke wants to
talk about
oh what a success my policy was right
well how do we know it's a success
interest rates are still at zero you
can't claim it's a success until you
normalize those rates let the Fed bring
interest rates back up to 5% let it take
its balance sheet from four and a half
trillion back down to a trillion and
then tell me how successful the policy
was because right now all they've done
is the easy part right it's like you
know you know it the easy part
of of drugs is getting addicted you know
anybody can start taking drugs right
it's easy to start a bad habit the hard
part is giving it up right same thing or
you know it's easy to gain a lot of
weight you could talk about going on a
diet but do it that's the hard part
ben bernanke and if they want to claim
credit for fixing the economy when
interest rates are still at zero and if
you actually look at what's happening in
the real economy since the Fed embarked
on this program becoming is a mess real
wages have fallen the labor force has
collapsed millions and millions of
people have left the labor force they're
no longer working labor force
participation has imploded and not for
the baby boomer or the baby boom in the
last month we got the jobs report that
just came out for October everybody was
so excited that we created two hundred
seventy-one thousand jobs yeah all those
jobs went to people 55 and older people
who were under 55 lost jobs and I read
that for males between the ages of 24
and 55 they lost 119 thousand jobs in
the month of October you know so what's
really going on is older Americans are
taking temporary jobs because they can't
afford to pay their electric bills
because the costs have gone up right the
cost of living is going up and they
don't have any interest on their CDs so
older Americans are coming out of
retirement to take jobs that they don't
want and then you maybe have maybe you
have some married women with children
who are forced to take a job because
their husband can't afford to support
them anymore you don't have a real
growing economy that is creating vibrant
productive jobs we're in much worse
shape than we were eight years ago look
at the average household net worth look
at home ownership home ownership is that
the lowest had spent in 50 years 50
years you know most people now you know
they're renting and the rents are rising
rapidly and they're going to continue to
rise and that's with the Federal Reserve
they got interest rates at zero and you
by a house with three and a half percent
down guaranteed by the government with
three and a half percent down and
Americans are still too broke to qualify
for that mortgage what would happen to
the housing market if interest rates
went up what would happen to housing
prices you know all those banks that
were too big to fail because so we
bailed them out they're way bigger now
they would all fail if the Fed were to
raise interest rates by any significant
amount they're all exposed we have a
gigantic automobile bubble we've got a
student loan bubble I mean here I'm
talking at a college right I mean look
where we got 1.3 1.4 trillion dollars
now I mean student debt is growing off
the charts even though college grads
can't even get jobs why are they buying
all this money when there's no jobs but
you got college kids waiting tables
driving taxis tending bar you don't need
to go to college for that but I think a
lot of the people who are borrowing
money don't even care about the college
they just want the money and going to
school is the way to get it because once
you enroll you can borrow the money you
use it to pay your rent you can use it
to buy groceries but people are living
off these college loans because there's
no real productive economy beneath the
surface the Fed has just got this
gigantic bubble so well I think what's
going to happen is either the Fed
doesn't raise interest rates at all in
December and continues to pretend that
there's some point in time where they're
going to do it and I think the reason
that they talk about raising interest
rates so much is because they know they
can't if they could raise them they just
would have done it but because they
can't do it they talk about it but the
one thing the Federal Reserve can admit
is that they can't raise rates because
if they admit that then the party's over
because that's an admission of failure
the whole idea is that this is temporary
but I remember when the Fed first
announced their quantitative easing
program I said that was it I said this
was a monetary roach motel I said in the
beginning that once you check in you
never check out right and and I said
that there was going to be more
quantitative easing than Rocky movies
this is when they did the first one
right so they had six Rocky movies and
by the way a seven
one is about to come out Stallone just
made another one with Apollo Creed's kid
so I mean we're gonna have more qyz then
then those rocky moves and how did I
know that how did I know from the
beginning that they would do so many
because I knew it wouldn't work and
because it wouldn't work they would do
it again right because that's how
government is it's like I described it
as you're trying to put out fire fire
with gasoline right and so you pour some
gasoline on the fire and then the fire
gets bigger and you think gee guess I
didn't pour out enough gas let me get
some more and then they pour more
gasoline and you know but the thing is
eventually you know they burn down the
whole forest right that is where we're
headed so the federal reserve keeps
pretending it's going to raise rates but
it doesn't do it because it must realize
oh my god if we raise rates that's the
party's over what happened when they
raised rates before we got the financial
crisis of 2008 I mean this would be much
worse
so they pretend so either they never
raise interest rates and the market
figures it out or they do raise interest
rates they feel okay we'll just raise it
by a quarter of a point that's it just a
quarter of a point and then we'll
promise not to do it again right they
might do that but either way the dollar
is going to start to fall buy the rumor
sell the fact or maybe it's there's no
fact to sell because it's all rumor but
this dollar bubble is going to burst and
as it starts to come down it's going to
start to force up commodity prices oil
prices are going to go back up other
prices go back up and the CPI is going
to start to rise above the feds 2% level
and remember the Federal Reserve said
well if inflation if unemployment gets
below six and a half percent we're going
to raise rates that's what they said
years ago and when they said that I said
no they won't right I said they're lying
I don't care where unemployment goes
they're not going to raise rates and
sure enough unemployment the way they
measure it is now five percent and they
haven't raised rates well I think the
same thing is going to happen with
inflation they say well 2% we get to
and 1/2 percent we get the 3% they're
not going to raise rates what because
they can't because we have too much debt
they don't want to bankrupt all these
financial entities but they're going to
have to pretend well you know they're
going to rationalize the inflation or
maybe it's transient or they'll try to
say that it's good for us but the feds
failure to raise rates and failure to
deal with inflation is going to put more
downward pressure on the dollar and
accelerate the process meanwhile you've
got a lot of our creditors who have
started already selling Treasuries the
Chinese have sold over a hundred billion
worth of Treasuries emerging market
economies in South America and Southeast
Asia who accumulated trillions and
trillions of dollars worth the US
Treasuries in 2010 2011 2012 remember
that ridiculous currency war right
everybody was trying to stop their
currency from rising as we were debating
ours and in order to do that they had to
buy all these Treasuries well now that
everybody thinks the feds about to raise
rates the dollar is risen and all those
currencies have plunged and now their
governments have all these Treasuries
which on paper have now appreciated in
their own currency what are they going
to do you got the Federal Reserve saying
well we're going to raise rates well if
they do raise rates in theory what
happens to the bond prices bond prices
fall so if you're a foreign central bank
and you've got these huge profits in
these US Treasuries you're going to take
them especially when you know that it's
a gigantic Ponzi scheme because you know
that the government can never pay back
any of that money right I mean so the
only way to get out is to sell there's
no redemption that's that's even
possible but I don't think that the
foreign central banks had bought up all
these dollars last time around they're
not going to fight currency World War
two they're going to let the dollar fall
and that means the dollars decline is
going to be much greater the next time
around and I think people are going to
get the message because we've already
had this expansion has gone on for about
six years and the typical length of the
US economic expansion is maybe five
years
I forget but we're already beyond it
right and yes it is the weakest recovery
ever but I also I don't think it's going
to be the longest - I have a pretty good
feeling that by next year we'll be in a
recession maybe if the Fed does QE for
early enough next year they can postpone
that recession until after the 2006
elections but that recession is coming
and when the dollar starts to fall
because we're not going to have all this
support from foreign central banks in a
fall quicker and then we're going to
start to deal with the inflation in
consumer prices you know a lot of people
say oh you know Peter Schiff was wrong
because he predicted that there'd be
inflation and we haven't had any well
the people who say that don't understand
what inflation is because we've had
plenty of inflation inflation is the
expansion of the money supply right
that's that's that's the literal
definition of inflate get an old
dictionary and look it up that's where
the word comes from inflate it sanics
when you inflate something you expand it
but what are we expanding prices don't
expand prices go up and they go down but
you can't inflate a price because prices
don't expand its money supply that
expands and contracts so the money
supply has been inflated and prices do
rise as a result of that but sometimes
different prices I said stock market
went way up why is it up is it because
corporations are any more money no is it
because the underlying plant equipment
is more valuable no in fact us plant
equipment is the oldest it's been in
over 60 years
I mean we've neglected our plant
equipment the value of our real assets
is going down even as the stock price is
going up that's all inflation has caused
that same thing with real estate prices
same thing with bond prices right I just
read I get on the paper some some guy in
Japan just paid 100 to 70 million
dollars for a photograph of a naked
woman I forget who the artist was those
the second second most expensive
Modigliani second most expensive
painting ever sold
that price is way up but sure where's
where's all that money coming from to
bid up these are prices so the Fed is
creating inflation but also consumer
prices are rising forget the way the
government wants to measure it look at
your own bills everything is getting
more expensive and you know given the
contraction in the economy given you
know how weak the economy is why aren't
prices falling why doesn't somebody ask
that question you know during the Great
Depression of the 1930s prices went down
by 30 percent and thank God for that
imagine how much worse the Depression
would have been if prices went up prices
going down relieves you know people say
oh we need more consuming it's not
enough to lower prices that's how you
get more demand lower prices right this
is a university they teach economics
right the most basic concept of
economics of supply and demand and
that's the law and what is supplied to
man say to lower the price to greater
the demand but the Federal Reserve
thinks it's the other way around they
think it's high prices that create
demand no it's low prices so if there's
not enough of demand you prices need to
come down and then people can afford to
buy things but no one asked hey why
aren't prices falling what's preventing
prices from coming down inflation is
preventing them from coming down the
government is robbing people the Federal
Reserve is robbing consumers of the
benefit of lower prices that's still
inflation but one of the reasons that
the inflation the Federal Reserve
creates is not Rutt runaway inflation is
because a lot of that money is offshore
owned by foreign central banks and what
do they buy with their excess dollars
they buy Treasuries they buy bonds
that's why bond prices are up in the
stratosphere but how does this how does
this work right the Federal Reserve
prints money and we use it to buy stuff
we buy real things real products that
you need factories to produce actual
labor people are sitting in a factory
doing something you know that requires
skill and they're making us a product
and what do they get in exchange for it
a piece of paper does it take any effort
on our part to print up money but it
took a lot of
to manufacture a consumer good and we
get we run five hundred billion dollar a
month a five hundred billion dollar
trade deficit right and so that's
keeping prices down right as we get to
export our inflation inflation is
America's biggest export right and we
import real things and the crazy part
about it is economists look at this and
think oh you know that somehow that you
know the we're we're the world is
somehow better off for this that we're
getting the short end of the stick you
know because we have these deficits but
the world is getting nothing I mean we
sucker them into giving us all their
stuff for the money that we print but
when they lose confidence in that when
they realize wait a minute the Fed is
stuck the Fed can't raise interest rates
and in fact if we've just gone through
this six year or seven year whatever
it's going to be if we go from you know
recession to recovery and back to
recession and the Fed has got interest
rates at zero the entire time that's
going to show people that this is the
new normal that we are now so addicted
to cheap money that even during a
recovery the Fed can't raise rates that
the only thing the Fed can do during the
business cycle is alter the amount of
quantitative easing so when the economy
is in recession they print a bunch of
money and when it comes out of recession
they print less right but interest rates
have to stay at zero the whole time
because they can no longer raise them
right it's like the economy like I've
used drugs but we have such a bad drug
habit we need so much drugs at this
point that even if they take a little
bit away we're you know we're going to
go through key economic convulsions so
when the our creditors our international
creditors realize this they will lose
confidence in the dollar and they're not
going to want to warehouse dollars
they're going to realize that hey if we
just sit on these dollars for five or
ten or twenty years they might not be
worth anything so they're not going to
want our dollars in exchange for their
products and so that's going to mean
that the inflation that we create stays
here right if we can't export our
dollars if the dollar is falling in
value and Americans can't use
dollars to buy foreign products what are
we going to buy wood products I mean we
don't you saw solid we make the products
ourselves you know one of the think
Donald Trump wants to do is well let's
let's put these big tariffs well I mean
tariffs could work in theory if you've
got an industry to protect but once your
industry is gone I mean what good are
the tariffs going to do it's just going
to raise prices because there is no
American substitute most of these
products that we import are not made
here it is in pot you can't make them
without a factory you can't make them
without labor that actually knows how to
operate the machines you know I mean 70%
of our so-called GDP is people just
spending money shopping you know I read
these articles about it how they you
know they they actually just fit that
this defines shopping as economic output
seventy percent of u.s. economic output
is consumer spending what do you put out
when you spend money nothing right
anybody can spend money the output
output is what you printed products that
you produce not not not when you just
consume what has already been produced
yeah what Americans do is we consume
what other people produced the economic
growth takes place outside the United
States we just borrow the money to pay
for the stuff so when they foreigners
lose confidence in the dollar then the
dollar is going to collapse and all that
inflation that we exported is going to
come back and then all the people have
said oh you know guys like Peter Schiff
or the Austrians C they said oh we were
wrong because there's no inflation we
were right they just don't know it yet
but by the time that inflation tsunami
washes back up on our shore is too late
to do anything about it you can't do
anything about it you know it's good you
know that's it right that genie is far
out of that out of the bottle but if you
just focus on on the consumer price and
not understand everything that's going
on you can be led to make the false
conclusion that hey we can print all
this money and there's no negative
consequences so let's just keep printing
more right that's kind of what the
Federal Reserve looks at they print all
this money interest rates aren't going
up consumer prices aren't going up oh I
guess I can keep prin
more there's no ill effect but if all of
this happens with a big lag and the
reason the lag is longer is because of
this you know international trip the
u.s. dollars the reserve currency and so
it's going to take a long time for all
this bad monetary policy to really blow
up on us but in the meantime as I said
you can see the results on a smaller
scale in you know in the in the real
economy where the average American is
suffering a decline in their standard of
living that we're not getting the
savings and investment necessary for
legitimate economic growth and so
instead we substitute this bubble
economy and we try to convince Americans
to take on more debt and buy more stuff
and how have we done that you know with
the auto bubble right Americans are
borrowing all this money to buy cars
they can't afford now car loans are like
7-8 years people are taking out
mortgages to buy cars and that's what 0%
financing right everything people are
buying it's all on credit right and and
this is what's keeping it going but
there is a limit to how much credit
people can can take on and at some point
of course it's the lenders that impose a
hard limit because they begin to realize
that they can't get paid back and when
it comes to our global creditors again
its purchasing power that counts any
sovereign that borrows in its own
currency can repay its debts if the
creditors don't care what the value of
the money is right I don't think this
embody a government defaulted on any of
its bonds it just paid them off in full
who cares
hey you know and there are plenty of
situations where governments have
borrowed in their own currency and then
you know printed it but people have
given the United States a lot of slack
in just assuming that we would right the
ship and that we would one day you know
come to terms with a debt but I think
it's because we've been able to get away
with it for so long there is no
political will in Congress the White
House or the Fed to actually do anything
about the debt yeah it's you know it's
good talking you know they're you're
going to have the Republican debate is
going to be on on Fox later today
and all the candidates are going to talk
about yeah I want a balanced budget yeah
all these candidates you know when I ran
for Senate is the same thing all the
candidates want to talk about a balanced
budget amendment we don't need a
balanced budget amendment just don't
raise the debt ceiling that's all you
have to do right and then and that's a
balanced budget but the reason that they
all want to say I'm for a balanced
budget amendment is because there is no
bowels have been budget amendment before
anybody can be for that because no one
ever has to vote for it but what they do
have to vote for is a debt ceiling raise
and they do that every time and they
again they just did it so when our
creditors realized that look there is no
solution to our debt problem it's just
more debt the government is never going
to prick this bubble on its own the
never government is not going to
restructure or admit that it's broke
it's just going to keep on Eddie look we
we're already broke and we added
Obamacare right we're Brett we're
bankrupt from our social security
liabilities from our Medicare
liabilities we have an enormous debt and
then we just added Obamacare on top of
that right and now they want more right
I mean look you got you know Bernie
Sanders wants college to be completely
free imagine how expensive it's going to
be when it's completely free look at
them look at how expensive it is now
because of the government but you know
so the fact that we're just going this
way it can only end it can only end in a
currency crisis and I'll wind it up
because I know I want to take questions
I'm not but when the dollar collapses
because the Fed is unable to raise
interest rates unable to fight inflation
and of course if the Federal Reserve
belatedly does the right thing that's a
big if if they end up raising interest
rates sharply by the time the Fed raises
rates they're not going to raise them a
quarter of a point they're going to have
to do it
Volcker style right maybe worse right
the Russia had to raise interest rates
to 17%
I don't know six months ago the ruble is
falling they raise interest rates is 17%
the Russian economy is still there
can you imagine the American economy if
we had to raise interest rates to 17%
what would it be like
see if they have to raise interest rates
even to 5% you know is we're gonna
collapse right and not only will all the
banks fail but the depositors are going
to lose their money see in the Oh a
crisis if nobody lost any money no
creditors not forget about depositors if
you owned a bond if you owned from a
bank you didn't lose the government
bailed out the bank and everybody nobody
lost any money but if the Federal
Reserve has to raise interest rates to
defend the dollar nobody can get a
bailout you can't bail anybody out if
the Fed is raising rates right that's
the opposite of bailing out there's no
money the Congress has no money if the
Fed is raising rates and selling
Treasuries right shrinking its balance
sheet right nobody gets bailed out so
not only will the bondholders lose money
the depositors will lose money because
the FDIC has no money there's nothing
there and in fact if the Federal Reserve
has to raise interest rates to fight
inflation the US government has to
default on the Treasury bonds they don't
have them they're not going to have the
money to pay the interest certainly you
know 1/3 of the unit of the US Treasury
bond market matures in the next year
what happens if our creditors want their
money back
we don't have it the government counts
on everybody rolling it over right
that's why you know when they first put
you know Bernie Madoff in jail they
interviewed him and he interview he was
in New York Times interviewed him and he
said in New York Times all you know yeah
I don't know why you guys are making a
big deal about me I mean I'm a [ __ ] I
mean the federal US government is
running a much bigger Ponzi scheme than
I did right and when that article first
came out people dismissed it right they
said oh we what does he know he's Bernie
Madoff right and I said well you know
he's he knows one thing right posi
schemes right he knows one what he sees
one he has credibility there because
they and that's why I said look why do
we have the guy in jail we should just
make it because he understands how to
deal with a Ponzi scheme because the
miles in Washington they even admit it's
a Ponzi scheme right what do they say
what did they just say a few weeks ago
if we don't raise the debt ceiling we're
going to default that's an admission
that it's a Ponzi scheme right and that
is its basic Ponzi Ponzi 101 if you are
running a Ponzi scheme don't tell
anybody
right you got to keep it quiet but we've
told everybody it's a Ponzi scheme so
they know so if the Fed raises interest
rates the US Treasury has to default
people that have bank accounts are going
to lose their money and the governor is
going to have to come clean with Social
Security recipients pensioners military
pension government civilian pension and
say you know what we promised you a lot
of money to get your votes but we spent
that money and now we're broke so we
can't give you what we promised that's
what would happen if the US Federal
Reserve did the right thing and raised
interest rates to stop the dollar from
becoming monopoly money the government
is going to have to be honest about the
financial situation and not pay people
their dollars now if they don't do that
then we're going to have a complete
collapse of the dollar and yes you go to
the bank
you'll get your money if you're
expecting a Social Security check it'll
be in the mail right but you're not
going to buy much with it see there is
no easy way out
if you borrow beyond your capacity to
repay the debts aren't paid you can be
honest about it and default or you could
be dishonest and inflate but either way
the consequences are the same the
creditor doesn't get his money because
the borrower is broke so either you get
your money and it doesn't buy you
anything or you get less money now
personally I think our creditors would
be better off if they got less money if
they took a haircut if we had a
legitimate restructuring and the
government paid the bondholders 30 cents
on the dollar if the government paid
Social Security recipients 30 cents on
the dollar or whatever or maybe they
just means tested it and asset tested it
and said look if you have money if you
have wealth you're not getting any
Social Security but if you're destitute
well you know you're going to get
something and you know
welfare I mean they can have different
ways to default on these commitments but
I think if they did that people would be
much better off than politicians trying
to pay everybody off with a printing
press because then I think the real loss
in purchasing power will be much greater
yes maybe you get a hundred cents on the
dollar but maybe your your 100 cents is
worth 2 cents right that's a much bigger
haircut than would be the case if the
government were to be honest but
hopefully hopefully in the aftermath of
this monetary crisis that is coming we
can finally learn from our mistakes and
start over right get rid of the Fed take
the power away from Congress you know
America became the wealthiest country in
the history of the world without a
central bank we were on a gold standard
I mean we didn't again we didn't have a
central bank until 1913 right we went
through the Industrial Revolution
without a central bank and yes you know
the momentum carried us through to the
Second World War but as the Bank has
grown and the government has grown in
tandem with the Federal Reserve you know
our wealth has been dramatically
diminished we're no longer the world's
wealthiest economy we're no longer we're
the world's biggest debtor our Communist
a complete disaster and so hopefully
rather than what happened in 2008 see in
2008 the government was successful in
its you know PR campaign a propaganda
campaign the government actually blamed
that crisis on capitalism they said oh
we didn't have enough regulation oh as
capitalism run amok too much greed the
solution was more government the Federal
Reserve actually got more power as a
result of the financial crisis even
though they created it right so
hopefully when it blows up again the
government won't be able to blame for
the free market or what's left of it you
know and that is one of the one of the
successes of government is they
infiltrate the free market they screw
stuff up and then when their
intervention causes a problem they blame
it on the free market and they say you
see this proves we need even more
government
and then they get more government and
then they screwed up more so hopefully
this next time this next crisis enough
people will understand the root cause of
it and we can have a backlash and go
back to sound money and limited
government and kind of reboot the
economy and start over again
and believe me you know we're in a deep
big hole because of 50 years of this
nonsense because of you know going off
the gold standard what this is done but
the the good news is that capitalism
works and if we could get rid of enough
government you know with all the
technology that we have today that we
didn't have a hundred years ago I mean
if America could be so successful in the
19th century with capitalism imagine how
successful we can be the 21st century
with the technology that exists today
imagine how much better capitalism would
work imagine how much more rapidly we
can raise the standard of living of our
people if the government simply get out
of the way and let it happen
thank you
all right so that's it on question hey
only spoke for 45 minutes or without it
I started for I spoke for an hour
Oh mr. Schiff thank you so much for your
time this evening I'm going to go back
to the Bob your talk about the Federal
Reserve and there's been a lot of
proposals right now on the floor of
Congress to audit the Fed three-part
question so first of all who should
audit the Fed what do they should they
look at when they audit the Fed and then
finally what do we do about it after
they do thank you so much for your time
yeah I was saying you know auditing the
Fed isn't even enough I mean just you
know but it would make sense for it to
be a little bit more transparent so the
whole idea is to find out what exactly
the Fed is doing because they're very
secretive how much money are they're
creating and what are they buying you
know because the fetters are you just
let them buy whatever they want I mean
right now they're buying not only they
buying Treasuries they're buying
mortgages they're buying consumer debt I
mean you don't really want to allow an
agent of government which is really look
to Federal Reserve is supposed to be a
private bank right but in fact it acts
as if it was an arm of the government
and that's not what it's supposed to do
but if they could just print money and
buy stuff I mean that's like
nationalization that's like the
government just confiscating wealth
I mean what's to stop the Federal
Reserve from buying stocks buying real
estate they can buy up the whole country
right in fact they're actually talking
about doing that in Japan they might end
up doing that here right so I think
auditing the Fed would be a good idea
just to kind of have a little bit better
understanding of what's going on behind
closed doors but what really has to
happen is is and it's not only just
eliminating the Fed but eliminating the
functions because I don't want Congress
to just do what the Fed is doing what
the Fed is doing shouldn't be done at
all and interest rates need to be
determined by the market not by a group
of men behind a closed door I mean I
mean does anybody think I mean interest
rates are at zero how can that possibly
be the correct price zero how
be right I mean is with the market set
interest rates at zero I mean think
about it to nobody is saving in America
and everybody is borrowing so interest
rates should be high plus we've got lots
of debt the more debt you have the
greater the chances are that you're not
going to pay it back so when interest
rates go up the market stops you from
borrowing right that's how the market
works right if there's a shortage of
savings then interest rates go up that
encourages more savings if people have
too much debt interest rates go up and
that stops the borrowing the market
works it doesn't work when the
government comes in and sets a price
just like it look you know that we don't
have we don't want the government to set
the price of bread because then there'd
be shortages there'd be long lines you
think did they have that the Soviet
Union right for a while they control the
price of gasoline then we had a wait in
line for gasoline because they didn't
let the market function right where they
said they'd have a minimum wage so that
means if you if you can't convince
somebody to pay the minimum wage you're
legally unemployable now they want to
raise it they want to throw more people
out of work I mean let the market set
prices but probably the most important
price in the economy is interest rates
and it needs to be set by the market and
also money money needs to have value it
can't just be a piece of paper money
money was created to replace barter
right where I gave you a chicken for a
pig right we everybody got something of
value well the concept of money was that
hey gold has value but it's easier to
trade if I have if I have if I want a
pig I don't have to find somebody who
wants to chicken I could just pay him
gold because everybody wants gold so
money started as a commodity it was a
commodity that was used as when any
commodity can theoretically be money but
gold works better than all the other
commodities and that's why it became
money for thousands of years but what we
got now isn't money
it's a substitute but it doesn't work as
a piece of paper right and initially we
talked about the federal reserve federal
reserve notes were backed 40% by gold
and they were redeemable 100% in gold
and silver if you had a $20 bill in
1913 it was redeemable it wasn't a $20
bill it was a $20 Federal Reserve Note
payable it was an IOU for $20 right it
was a note which is a debt instrument
right that's why they're called Federal
Reserve notes because it's a debt it's a
liability the Federal Reserve and what
did the Federal Reserve owe you they
owed you $20 what was $20 an ounce the
gold that's what you were owed if you
owned a Federal Reserve Note what do you
own now if you have a Federal Reserve
know nothing what does the Federal
Reserve promise to pay you for a $20
bill nothing two tens four fives you
know you don't get anything it's if I
don't even know why they call it a note
yes it's technically a liability on
their balance sheet but they're not
liable for anything they don't have to
pay you anything it's not real money it
was supposed to be real money but it
isn't anymore it's just snow different
than monopoly money next Thank You mr.
chef yeah